bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france après ses deux
nouveaux soldats français tués au mali
est ce qu'on peut dire que l'opération
barkan et efficace réellement au sahel
il faut vérifier cette efficacité non
pas à l'aune d'un malheureux incident
qui s'est déroulé hier dans lequel deux
aux soldats ont été tués et l'un
grièvement blessé salué le courage de
l'ensemble de nos soldats qui
continuaient le combat là bas mais le
vérifier à l'aune de ce qui a été fait
lors du sommet de nouakchott
début juillet ou en six mois environ 600
g listes ont été neutralisés et où dans
la zone des trois frontières la sécurité
propres progressivement revient cet
incident vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure et du en fait à une engin
explosif qui a explosé sous un véhicule
blindé
il reste à savoir puisqu'il n'ya pas une
embuscade n'y a pas eu tir qui avait
personne autour de cette bombe dans
quelle mesure
ceci était une bombe posée à bon escient
j'allais dire par les djihadistes devant
une patrouille française ou si c'était
une bombe qui était resté là depuis un
certain temps si on devait faire l'état
des lieux de la menace jihadiste
dans le pays dans le nord
particulièrement vous dites que la
sécurité revient que diriez-vous 1 je
dirais que il n'est pas tout de
neutraliser les djihadistes il faut
encore que les états reprennent place
dans ces zones
et c'est là qu'est la difficulté et
c'est là que les liens avec ce qui se
passe au mali avec le coup d'état
actuellement que les forces françaises
et les forces du g5 voir la minus ma
établissent la sécurité dans ces zones
c'est une bonne chose mais derrière il
faut que les états reviennent
et lorsqu'on a un état instable
naturellement il ne revient pas comme ça
d'ailleurs dans la région de tessalit tu
où a eu lieu l'incident
nous ne sommes pas loin de kidal et
kidal c'est la zone dans laquelle
l'armée malienne n'était pas revenu elle
est revenue aujourd'hui mais de façon un
peu symbolique et il faut absolument que
toutes les composantes des états
reviennent pour prendre la place de ces
mouvements djihadistes et montrer que
l'état de droit apporte la paix et la
sécurité aux populations au lieu des
djihadistes qui apporte l'insécurité
alors l'état de droit aussi c'est c'est
une armée professionnelle efficace
on l'a vu les récents événements
au mali avec ce coup d'état militaire
finalement cela pose encore des
questions sur les capacités des armées
africaines à jouer leur rôle pleinement
et
et à se professionnaliser oui alors vous
avez raison il ya deux aspects la
formation de ses armées africaines
je rappelle que l'union européenne par
la mission outils m est très engagé sur
la formation des bataillons et des
soldats maliens
donc ça c'est l'aspect tactique ou
opérationnelles si vous voulez l'autre
aspect que vous soulignez avec le coup
d'état et la l'état de droit j'allais
dire sans du tout justifié bien sûr
quelque chose qui est il légal qu'il y
avait des manifestations depuis
longtemps de la population à bamako est
en fait l'armée a retrouvé les
manifestations manifestants de bamako
pour changer le régime alors ceci est
bien sûr illégal mais on peut considérer
vu de la position je suis qui lie à
coïncidence entre ce que voulait la
population est ce que l'armée a procuré
maintenant il faut rapidement si j'ose
dire
rentré dans le rang et que les armées
arrivent à coordonner avec les les
forces civiles
un retour à la paix et à la légalité
avec des élections en particulier au
mali alors ça nous amène finalement à la
coopération sécuritaire
entre les pays occidentaux et certains
pays africains par exemple si on prend
l'exemple du sahel il ya l'opération
barkan il ya eu l'opération serval
l'opération par cal maintenant les mines
usma et présente également au mali faut
le préciser
et il ya eu aussi dans le cadre d'une
coopération européenne la cette force
takouba finalement on a du mal à y voir
clair dans toute cette coopération
militaire mais d'abord il ya
probablement beaucoup de coopération il
en vaut mieux trop que pas assez
si vous permettez alors la coopération
est de deux ordres
sur le plan tactique il ya la
coopération avec les pays du g5 sahel
j'ai cité tout à l'heure la formation de
l'union européenne mais aussi le travail
conjoint
la décision qui avait été à prier à sa
peau était concentré les forces sur
l'art la zone des trois frontières ce
qui est fait et à provoquer les
résultats que j'ai déjà cité et l'unité
du commandement avec un pc commun et
puis vous avez cité que takouba takouba
qu'est ce que c'est ce sont des forces
européennes pour bien montrer que la
france n'est pas seule
alors la france n'était pas seule sur le
plan logistique des hélicoptères danois
des hélicoptères britanniques des avions
allemands d avion espagnol mais au
combat il y avait quasiment que les
français maintenant la fosse takouba
commence son implication sur le terrain
avec les forces du g5 sa haine
les français et les estoniens dans un
premier temps mais aussi sont annoncées
des tchèques des italiens des espagnols
des belges
les belges viennent d'annoncer non
seulement des forces spéciales mais
probablement un groupement tactique
complet donc on voit que petit petit à
petit les européens à s'impliquer et il
faut que nos frères africains
comprennent qu'ils ne sont pas seuls
dans cette lutte et que nous allons les
accompagner
longtemps ça c'est sur le plan tactique
maintenant au plan politique et je là je
m'adresse bien sûr à la situation
actuellement à bamako et au mali il faut
absolument que les maliens prenne les
choses en mains et reviennent à une les
qualité qui permettent aux européens de
travailler avec eux car ils ne pourront
pas travailler longtemps avec un avec
des putschistes il faut forcément que
ceux-ci s'entende avec la société civile
malienne alors très rapidement vous
parliez du g5 sahel c'est vrai que les
membres de l'organisation ont reproché
aussi le l'absence de soutien financier
pour faire avancer l'opérationnalisation
de du g5 sahel alors vous avez raison
c'est compliqué mais il ya de l'argent
qui arrive à l'union européenne a
consacré des moyens déjà aujourd'hui au
g5 sahel le prochain budget européen
comprend tout un volet militaire et un
volet de facilite ptp européenne qui
doit permettre d'équiper ses bataillons
le problème c'est d'arriver à suivre
tout cela est de mettre en place un
dispositif qui à la fois finances s'est
armé pour leur permettre de lutter elle
même contre ses ennemis dans leur pays
mais en plus de les accompagner dans la
durée c'est à dire pas seulement le
livre est brutalement des matériels mais
les accompagner dans la durée pour
qu'ils ne se sentent pas seuls merci à
vous dominique train quand j'appelle
cause vous êtes expert des questions
militaires et ancien chef de la mission
militaire française à l'onu